again bruce is in wellington on zoom so
he's asked me to
share this
and we have live streaming
yes very good welcome to our zoo
attendees
so we have apologies from councillor
clark and councillor pottinger are there
any other apologies
i haven't heard from the council yet
just my
big signs that you can't do mondays is
that
yeah that's my understanding
[Music]
we moved the risk and assurance meetings
regular time to a different day of the
week because she couldn't do mondays
uh please move that those apologies
except thank you councillor arnold thank
you councillor madison all those in
favor please say aye
against abstentions carrie
thank you
there are no changes to the agenda
jackson may just ask because there are
one two pertinent matters
not members of the committee involved in
the like any votes that go on today
please
i've been
chief executives chief executive
advisers yes uh the reason i say that uh
mr chair is that uh the chairperson on
zoom would always say yes to that
question
i would like to raise a few issues on
point two
point five
and
point ten right we'll let you do that
when we get to those items your worship
uh
jane can i pass to you
to introduce this please
thank you mr chair i'll just make a few
points um to set the scene if you like
um first of all the main purpose of this
report you'll find that in the third
paragraph or just read it out
the main purpose of this report is to
suggest a plan to transition the eas
away from council over the next six
months or so
in a way that retains the progress that
has been made to date and enables
council to continue to build its own
capability
um secondly just a reminder of some of
the key dates um that's got us to where
we are today
these are mostly um
to be found in page five but i'll just
run through them quickly
and add a few other
um dates in there
so august 2020 we got a letter from dia
october 2020
we received a governance review
from richard thompson
november 2020
council resolved to develop a working on
working together action plan
december 2020 council appointed two eas
jeff and lindsay for a period of up to
six
18 months from january 2021
august
2021 we had this
six-month review
again
from richard plus an impact consulting
survey
september 21
council
resolved passed a suite of resolutions
to guide the next steps of the working
on working together project
and that included the transition plan
for the eas
which brings us to today's report
if i was talking to slides this is this
third slide
the proposed plan
in this report
have been guided by
the six months review and the impact
consulting survey which i've already
mentioned
the council resolutions in september
which i've already mentioned they're an
appendix d
on page five you'll find the views of
the eas themselves
and on page six the views of the project
governance group
and that of course includes
the department of internal affairs
so from all of that
the last slide of our head slide
would summarize the key elements of the
plan
firstly a revised purpose membership
including a proposed new chair of the
the
governance group
secondly a revised purpose
and membership including co-chairs for
the chairs group
thirdly reduced presence of both eas at
council and committee meetings
fourthly the ea's role
moving to supporting mentoring
and process focus
fifthly the inclusion
of a supporting the mayor's group
um in the working on working together
plan
and you'll find that all
attached as appendix b i think it is
and you'll notice that the working
groups have
disappeared all of this to start on the
the 1st of december that of course will
depend on
this committee's resolutions to council
and council's views
on the i think it's 23rd
then we have a progress check in march
followed by a closeout or legacy report
um to go to dia for their response
so we start with a later and we finish
with a close-out report and ask for the
response from dia
so mr chair i hope that's
enough to set the scene for
questions and discussion thank you
thank you very much jane thank you for
the paper and work you've done
uh firstly could i ask bruce to
make comments in respect to that
yeah thanks
was going to say then i'd ask the eas to
make some comments on their retirement
plan
yeah thanks ross i
look support the approach paper clearly
it's come through the project governance
group
which
sit on
and it's been worked through well in
that sense
i also just conscious that actually
the risk and insurance committee has
been tasked throughout this process to
provide that
the quasi-independent standard side view
of actually progress so i'm reminded of
our objective
which in my view is to enable council
to operate
in a manner which meets the department's
expectations and indeed really the
expectations of the local government
and it seems to me that actually this is
a really important step
um because i think it's wise um and i've
used it in a way but it may not be the
way gentlemen
train wheels off
uh and prove to ourselves into the
department that we can
manage our
ways in the manic
this is a a
pathway
for dealing with that the other thing
which i think is really important ross
and i couldn't help but notice from the
government's group
and also james paper
is richard hardy's wise words
this is now the risk time
which actually we need to do this for
ourselves
with the minimized support of the ea so
in short ross very happy with the pro
rest to date i think we're ready to take
this move and i strongly endorse the the
general antenna and nate pacific nature
change recommendations
thank you very much bruce
lindsey and jeff any comments you wish
to make at this stage
look thank you mr chair if i could start
we also
support the approach that's being
proposed
to council through risk insurance today
we appreciate the extent to which our
views have been taken into account
in
reporting the proposed pathway forward
i can also say that at least within the
chairs group and with pgg to an extent
also there's been a degree of
socialization of these proposals and
there's a high probability that there
will be a
strong measure of support when they get
to the council table
and finally i think we just need to
proceed on an eyes wide open basis and
maintain a degree of flexibility and
resilience if the
future circumstance
requires it and the path is not as
smooth as we anticipate
thank you
jeff is there anything you wish to add
thanks ross uh look no justin
jane has captured really well the
conversations have taken place since pgg
and
in terms of recommendations fully
support
thank you
now invite discussion
questions and comments
sit up yes thank you mr chief
i just had a few questions i wish to
raise
um and it was of course where does the
mayor fit into all this
um
the cex official
which is
the normal case with um
committee standing committees but this
is
in a different area
um
so so it's my understanding uh statement
continues
both in
this recommendations that mania would be
sufficient to both
the pgg and also the cheese group has
currently exists
um
mr chair i think it's a question that
mrs pathet as the report author might
best be
able to comment on
i don't believe that the
um
organization of this group has had
ex-officio members
previously but
jane may be better able to comment
there was certainly an expectation that
the mayor
was included in the project governance
group and the mayor is a regular
attendance there and we would expect
that
to continue
and
i'm just looking at the chairs group the
mayor
will continue with the same
level of
inclusion
that he has had
so i guess the short answer is we just
continue on as previously with the
mayor's input
wherever he feels he wishes to
be
no change
from the current operating
environment
and would claire have voting rights
um
[Music]
yes as a member of that committee
yeah and i'll just remind you that the
chair um to date
has
taken a
a collaborative approach and we haven't
needed to have any votes and that would
continue as well
so tim did you have another question
um it's also going to raise um
0.5
um
sort of
the tendency would be to
have a sort of a team and a b team
and that could evolve from that
sort of
we don't have an upper house but that's
where it would fit in the
um
i would think that the purpose of
the group and the collaborative approach
that's been taken to date would be
all-inclusive and
full knowledge sharing
and i've
from what i've witnessed has been pretty
open discussion
uh and information passed to all
councillors
and if i could just add to that mr chair
the the intention going forward
is for more counsellors i think there's
a suggestion that three councillors
move on to the
governance group
um
the chair of the governance group is an
elected member
as with the chairs group so this is
going to be
more involvement from more counsellors
going forward
the chairs group isn't a
structured
part of the structure of the council
can you just pull your microphone sorry
jane won't be hearing you
but you are correct the chairs group is
not part of the formal structure of
council
but it is part of the working on working
together project
and
you can see it on appendix b
how it fits in
to this project
thanks councillor arnold uh yeah just
probably
follow on from what uh his worship
saying there um
yes i look at um
number two and the
the future makeup of this group
it says three other elected members not
members of the cheers group yet down on
number five you're recommending the two
co-chairs
of
the groups to be part of that two of
those three is that is that correct am i
correct i'm assuming that
so it's three as well as those two
no no
no
so the co-chairs are the co-chairs for
the cheers group and then the pgg is the
one that's going to have three other
people who aren't chairs or part of the
cheers group added to them
that's right
so if i'm looking at membership in the
chair up top it says the deputy mayor
ceo of council
representative dia chair chair of risk
and insurance committee three other
elected members not members of the
cheese group and two eas that's for the
pgg
the governor's corporate committee
that pg g and cheers so this is not this
is not the same thing
no that's correct if you look at
appendix b you'll see that two different
his worship asked a question that came
across
uh and and the matter got a little i
think we didn't quite hear the question
and the zoom answer so it's
understandable it was confusion the
project governance group has always had
that composition
and the suggestion is three more
councillors who are neither cheers nor
deputy chairs okay
oh that's good i agree with that because
i'd just like to see you a little bit
more uh yep
thanks councillor ludlow
thanks cheer i think it's worth pointing
out that neither of those committees
make decisions apart from council chairs
group can only
do
make decisions if they've been delegated
to it specifically which has only
happened once
and pgg has to bring recommendations
back to to counsel your worship so
there's
you know the the final say always rests
with council
it's interesting though that the
thompson report
referred to actual support for the mayor
and that's been changed now to
well-being
for the mayor
and
just seems a bit wishy-washy
to have that um
i think that was referred to your
worship in the initial thompson report
i think the follow the second report
in review
um it moved on from then
are there any further questions
well the term leadership of course comes
it raises its head
in various areas
and
again
it seems that um
all the blame is being lumped on me
but
the
and i try and fit it into my life and
it's
it's why um
the leadership issue is
sleet at home
to me and i was
at primary school i was
milk monitor and
class captain
and bus cat captain
and then i went on to
[Music]
um
high school and i became a head prefect
and then
the student got to university and became
a student leader
and then went into local government and
did
two terms
in waimata city and
12 terms here in invercargill city
and i've just never been in a situation
where i'm not a leader
and
[Music]
it's
just hard to understand the reasoning or
why there's been a change
with respect to tim uh this matter is
not about leadership it's about the
transition plan for the
external appointees
bruce is there anything you want to add
in at this time
well i think i think um
there is the challenge that we're facing
which is though ross leadership and and
i think
we need to recognize including this
worship the process that we've gone
through to get ourselves to this point
and actually what is a feasible way to
get ourselves
effectively um to
the finish line which
is the current training
so
um the right evidence is that we've gone
through a process in response to
observed behaviors
by the department
um and we've responded and i think we i
think we we all have to accept
the modifications in the way which
leadership has achieved within the
council
and actually the the firmer basis that
we are now wrong going for
it still requires everybody to play the
apartment
if there is
any last questions
other
otherwise i was going to move through
the
resolutions that we have in front of us
i was going to propose that we take them
individually and
unless there is a
consensus
from the committee that they'd like to
move them
in bulk
i have no problem moving them all this
block
and i'll be happy to second that
do you
be helpful to the council meeting if the
names were
if we could have if we could have the
three nut for 0.3 yes yep
um
i could put uh councillor sopa
councillor scout and councillor lewis if
they were interested in willing
more questions
i'm seeing nods of approval i don't see
the motion
here
so
the membership uh would be the deputy
mayor
the ceo
representative from
gia
chair of the council's
risk insurance
committee
and three other elected members
who are not members of the cheers group
and two eas
that is great
well i
i feel uneasy about it i don't think
it's
part of local government law
as i understand it to change
structures and of responsibilities
is a
process you've got to go through
and i don't think it's
enhancing our democratic spirit to have
changes of the scale
so i'll be voting against it and have my
name recorded
uh councillor ludlow you want to make a
point
with respect your worship the whole
process is one that we
outlined to dia at the beginning
there was always a proposal to
begin to transition out before the next
election and that's simply what we're
going through now there's no
deviation from that original plan that
we put forward through after we received
their initial letter
well with all due respect i still think
that
the word actual support for the mayor
being changed to
well-being
it's
sort of lowering the value of that
appointment
or change
note your points the uh
resolutions have been moved and seconded
could i
please ask those
to vote now those in favor please say hi
to those resolutions
again jane thank you very much for the
work you've done
in the paper
there are no further items of business
so thank you for your attendance and
those on zoom and i declare the meeting
closed thank you very much
thank you guys
you